una tienda de impresión fotográfica
cobra a sus clientes 29 centavos por
imprimir una foto para clientes nuevos
la tienda tiene un descuento único de 3
dólares
escriba una función que represente la
cantidad que debe pagar un nuevo cliente
para imprimir x número de fotos
x es el número de fotos a imprimir
un cliente regular tendría que pagar x
fotos por 29 centavos cada una digamos
que es la cantidad de pagar que es la
cantidad de pagar y para un cliente
normal este es igual a 29 centavos o
punto 29 por el número de fotos pero no
os preguntan lo que pagaría un nuevo
cliente que tiene un descuento único de
3 dólares así que el nuevo cliente tiene
que pagar esto menos 3 que son los 3
dólares del descuento único por ser
nuevo cliente esta es una forma
generalizada aunque algo inexacta pues
qué pasa si el cliente imprime fotos que
tienen un total menor a 3 dólares
imaginemos que el cliente ordena 10
fotos 10 fotos por punto 29 a pues va a
ser igual a 2.9 no llega a los 3 dólares
esto menos 3 va a dar menos 10 centavos
y el cliente no va a pagar menos 10
centavos es como si la tienda le tuviera
que pagar 10 centavos por imprimir 10
fotos del cliente
qué podríamos hacer para tener la
función más exacta es esto lo que el
nuevo cliente nuevo cliente
gente
gente pagará
y va a ser igual a 0.29 x menos 3
y x es mayor a 10 y pagará nada cero
en otro caso que sería que fuera menor o
igual a 10 en otro caso
aquí está mi función más precisa para
expresar esto se imprime menos de 10
fotos no va a tener que pagar nada